The Game of Thrones prequel series, House
of the Dragon, although based on George RR
Martin's Targaryen history book Fire & Blood,
will not feature Targaryens only, but many
other houses and many other legendary figures
from that time period as well, including Tyland
Lannister, who in opinion of many was the
hardest and most loyal guy of them all. This
guy was literally tortured at one point in
most horrific ways and yet refused to betray
the secrets of his sworn King. If there is
any man that served the Hand of the King role
as good and efficient as Tywin Lannister did
to the Mad King, then it's Tyland Lannister.
Tyland fought for Queen Alicent's son Aegon
II and the Greens, but also served the Blacks
and Rhaenyra's son Aegon III and yet he never
broke an oath and remains one of the most
loyal characters in the histroy of Westeros.
House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022. Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan
Condal will serve as showrunners and executive
producers. George R. R. Martin will also serve
as executive producer. It’s based on George
RR Martin’s book Fire And Blood volume 1
and on Martin’s yet unfinished Fire And
Blood volume 2 book. “Fire & Blood begins
their tale with the legendary Aegon the Conqueror,
creator of the Iron Throne, and goes on to
recount the generations of Targaryens who
fought to hold that iconic seat, all the way
up to the civil war that nearly tore their
dynasty apart.” That's Fire And Blood volume
1. The yet unreleased Fire And Blood volume
2 will continue from where part 1 ended, with
Rhaenyra Targaryen's son Aegon lll's reign
and will cover Blackyre rebellions, war with
Dorne and go all the way to the Mad King and
Robert's Rebellion that ended Targaryen dynasty.
The key event of the show is also the key
in a history of House Targaryen, the Dance
of the Dragons - the Targaryen civil war,
which divided the entire kingdom and launched
a huge war that was fought from 129 AC to
131 AC. The Dance of the Dragons was the most
devastating war in the history of the Seven
Kingdoms. A war of succession between Aegon
II and his half-sister Rhaenyra over their
father Viserys I's throne. Both of them thought
they belonged on the Iron Throne. When people
started declaring for one of them or the other,
their fight divided the kingdoms in two.
Targaryens fought Targaryens, brothers fought
brothers, dragons fought dragons. By the time
it was over, thousands were dead.
Before the Targaryen civil war started, and
thus in season 1, Ser Tyland Lannister is
a knight from House Lannister. He serves on
the small council at King's Landing, as master
of ships for King Viserys I Targaryen, but
throughout his life he will also serve as
master of coin for Aegon II Targaryen, and
as the Hand of the King for Aegon III Targaryen.
He is the younger twin brother of Jason Lannister,
the Lord of Casterly Rock. When the Dance
of the Dragons starts, Tyland is one of the
most prominent enemies of Rhaenyra, but in
his youth, to be more precise, in 112 AC,
Ser Tyland and his older twin, Ser Jason,
vied for the hand of Princess Rhaenyra Targaryen,
but with no success. Eventually, Tyland was
named master of ships by Rhaenyra’s father,
King Viserys I Targaryen. On the night of
the death of King Viserys I Targaryen, Tyland
gathered with the other members of the small
council in Queen Alicent Hightower's chambers.
There, they discussed the succession until
dawn. During the meeting, Tyland pointed out
that many of the lords who had sworn to defend
the succession of Princess Rhaenyra back in
105 AC were long dead. He remarked that it
had been twenty-four years and that he himself
swore no such oath, as he had been a child
at the time, and sided with Alicent’s son,
Aegon, to make him King rather than have Rhaenyra
as the Queen of the Seven Kingdoms. At the
start of the Dance of the Dragons, Ser Tyland
was named master of coin by Dowager Queen
Alicent Hightower. Upon his appointment, Tyland
acted at once to seize the royal treasury
which proved to be one of the best decisions
the Greens have made during this entire war,
but also a decision that would later be the
reason of a horrendous torture upon him. The
crown's gold was divided into four parts.
One part was entrusted to the care of the
Iron Bank of Braavos for safekeeping, another
sent to Casterly Rock and the third to Oldtown.
The remaining wealth was used by the Greens
for bribes and gifts and hiring sellswords.
When King Aegon got severely wounded in a
dragon fight, and Prince Aemond Targaryen
was the Prince Regent and Protector of the
Realm, Tyland favored Aemond's suggestion
of bringing battle to Prince Daemon Targaryen
and fighting the rebellious river lords. This
proved to be the biggest mistake the Greens
could do. By leading an entire army and the
biggest dragon, Vhagar, out of King’s Landing
to fight Daemon in the Riverlands, Aemond
gave Daemon, Rhaenyra’s husband and the
most experienced general in Westeros, an opportunity
to avoid Aemond and instead go for the defenseless
King’s Landing and to put his wife Rhaenyra
on the Iron Throne, which he did. When Rhaenyra
took King's Landing in 130 AC, Tyland was
among the members of the court who emerged
from Maegor's Holdfast. Tyland was taken and
given to Rhaenyra's torturers, in hopes that
some of the Crown's treasury could be recovered.
However Tyland Lannister proved to be the
most loyal man in Westeros and refused to
tell where the gold had been sent, despite
being blinded, gelded, and mutilated by torturers.
After yet another fall of King’s Landing
and after Rhaenyra fled the capital, Ser Tyland
was released by the gutter knights of Ser
Perkin the Flea, who had seized the Red Keep
to install his squire, Trystane Truefyre,
as king on the Iron Throne. After the city
was taken back by the greens, Tyland was re-installed
as master of coin. As the armies of the North,
the Vale and the Riverlands, all loyal to
Queen Rhaenrya were preparing to march on
King's Landing, Tyland suggested sailing to
Lys or Tyrosh to hire sellsword companies
to fight for Aegon II, but Corlys Velaryon
insisted that Tyland could never return with
the sellswords in time. When King Aegon II
suggested sending Rhaenyra's son, Prince Aegon
the Younger, to the Wall, or gelding him to
ensure Rhaenyra's line would end with her
only remaining son, Tyland argued for harsher
course. He suggested Aegon's execution, insisting
that Aegon would always be a threat to the
king, as long as he lived. Tyland was later
dispatched across the narrow sea to find sellswords
in Pentos, Tyrosh, and Myr.
Tyland returned to King's Landing from Myr
shortly after King Aegon II Targaryen's death.
He was made the Hand of the King for the very
same guy he wanted to execute, King Aegon
III Targaryen at the start of his regency.
He began wearing a silken hood over his head
on formal occasions, as ladies new to court
were known to faint when seeing his face,
the result of all the torture Rhaenrya’s
men did to him. His hood, however, gave cause
to whispers among the smallfolk, who considered
him a malign masked sorcerer and began calling
him "the hooded hand". Despite having previously
served King Aegon II and having argued for
the death of Aegon III before his coronation,
and despite the fact that Aegon III’s mother
tortured him, Tyland served the new king loyally.
Tyland set out to restore trade to the Seven
Kingdoms, which had collapsed during the war.
He abolished taxes that had been enacted by
Queen Rhaenyra Targaryen and Lord Bartimos
Celtigar, gave out loans for rebuilding the
holdings which had been destroyed during the
war, and ordered the construction of three
huge fortified granaries throughout the kingdom,
and had them filled with grain. He also ordered
the repair and restoration of the Dragonpit,
strengthened the city gates, and announced
funding for the construction of fifty new
war galleys, although only ten were eventually
commissioned. When war erupted once more in
the Stepstones, Tyland refused the offers
made by envoys from Pentos, Braavos, and Lorath
to form an alliance against the legendary
pirate, Racallio Ryndoon, insisting to the
regents of Aegon III that it was wiser to
keep out of the wars of the Free Cities. In
early 133 AC, when it was discovered that
Winter Fever had broken out across the city
and the realm, Tyland ordered the gates of
the city and the Red Keep closed, to prevent
the disease from spreading. But as the Winter
Fever was nearing its end, Tyland himself
fell ill. He died after only two days, in
the presence of Septon Eustace and King Aegon
III, who took his hand as Tyland took his
last breath.
Tyland is one of the most important characters
in this story.
By moving three-quarters of the Crown’s
gold from King’s Landing while Aegon II’s
master of coin, Tyland had sown the seeds
of Queen Rhaenyra’s downfall,
a stroke of cunning that would, in the end,
cost him his eyes, ears, and health, and cost
the dragon queen her throne and her very life.
Yet it must be said that he served Rhaenyra’s
son well and faithfully.
Tyland Lannister will definitely be one of
the most interesting characters in the House
of the Dragon. An honorable man who lives
and breaths for the realm. Dutiful as it gets,
Tyland's loyalty is that big that he enters
the war healthy as it gets, but at the end
of the Targaryen civil war, he's blind, broken
eunuch for he never betrayed the side he fought
for.
All of this and more, Game of Thrones prequel
show, House of the Dragon, brings in 2022.
Thank you so much for watching. If you enjoyed
this video please give it a big thumbs up
and I hope to see you in the next one. Peace!